kann mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde vor einigen jahren habe ich
bereits ein video hier auf meinem kanal
hochgeladen in dem wir uns einen
grundschul test vorgeknöpft haben heute
werden wir quasi genau das gleiche
machen nur mit einem hauptschulabschluss
test ich bin gespannt wie sich reißen
werde die leute herzlich willkommen bei
wissenswert da einige von euch haben
eventuell schon das video von galileo
gesehen
96 prozent der deutschen haben
mindestens den sogenannten quali oder
einen höheren schulabschluss aber würdet
ihr denn auch
schaffen komme luca mit sicherheit die
teilnehmer haben sich echt gut
geschlagen okay und wir haben uns
gefragt ob ihr das auch schaaf wir haben
hier für euch jeweils vier fragen aus
den bereichen deutsch mathe und
gesellschaftskunde hatte
vielleicht war dies doch nicht hoch
richtige antwort gibt es einen punkt und
wir mindestens drei der vier fragen
richtig beantworten um einen der
bereiche zu bestehen okay
wenn wir insgesamt zwölf fragen
444 und ich muss 33 3 richtig
beantworten um zu bestehen die aufgaben
sind identisch mit denen aus der
bayrischen quali also der bayerischen
hauptschulabschlussprüfung ok diesen
test besteht dann hättet ihr
höchstwahrscheinlich auch die
hauptschule prüfung bestanden ok legen
wir los mit deutsch ganz kurze
vorwarnung hier war sind nicht warum
aber info ich habe mich null hierauf
vorbereitet
wir gucken einfach nur ob ich mit meinem
kenntnisstand ich habe vor sechs oder
sieben jahren oder so mein abi gemacht
ob ich es damit schaffen würde das hier
zu bestehen aufgabe 1 es geht um das
wort qualifikation wie viele silben hat
das wort qualifikation
qualifikation
oder
ich bin ich los ich glaube wenn man sich
selber vor spricht denkt man es in fünf
silben beim anziehen so ausspricht aber
es ist ja zu und also kion also ich
würde sagen auf jeden fall
67 aber ich bin mir 0 sicher richtig ist
[Musik]
ich sag's euch kein einziger fehler
heute nenne das entsprechende werk von
qualifikation in der grundform
qualifizieren
oder bin ich dumm
qualifiziert richtig ist qualifizieren
ich glaube das hat jeder von euch
gewusst oder was ist der plural von
qualifikationen die qualifikationen
richtig qualifikationen was gemacht
also ich will das überhaupt nicht
schlecht reden und ich glaube das hat
sich auch über die letzten drei jahre
sehr krass verändert weil das videos von
anfang 2018 aber dass das das sind dass
das sind wirklich aufgaben aus der
hauptschulabschlussprüfung
okay aber deutsch bin ich auch ganz
ehrlich war immer easy deutsch war auch
entspannt ich bin halt ein bisschen
excited für mathe gleich aus welcher
sprache stammt das wort qualifikation
ursprünglich ich würde sagen latein
irgendwie stand alles außen latte eine
schon qualifikation hört sich schon so
lateinisch an
qualifikation stammt aus dem
lateinischen
4 von 4 punkten
machen wir weiter mit maxl reden wir los
was sind 30 prozent von 1600
erstmal zehn prozent nehmen das 160 und
160 x 3 sind 300 sind 480
ich weiß nicht ob das sinn ergibt weil
ich es gerade gemacht habe wichtig ist
aber es war auch die erste matheaufgaben
das kann auch glück gewesen sein zwei
orte auf einer landkarte sind genau 15
zentimeter voneinander entfernt die
charta den maßstab 1 zu 100.000 wie weit
sind die orte tatsächlich voneinander
entfernt ok 22 orte 15 zentimeter 15 cm
x
hunderttausend sind 15 millionen
zentimeter das sind warte mal pausieren
man hat ja auch in abschlussprüfer ist
ja auch genug zeit also kannst du
natürlich selbst einteilen ist natürlich
auch nicht unendlich viel zeit aber 1,5
millionen zentimeter in meta sind
[Musik]
15.000 meter also 15 kilometer
glaube ich 100.000 zentimeter
entsprechend 1000 meter was wiederum
einem kilometer entspricht sie sind also
15 kilometer voneinander entfernt ich
habe es bisher nur das wusstest dann
merkt ihr auch hier wieder ein punkt ich
hab's bisschen doof ist ein viertel von
1 meter 20 ich habe es ein bisschen doof
ausgerechnet gerade aber hatte ja das
gleiche ergebnis 15 km h was man schon
immer ich habe schon irgendwie doof
ausgerechnet ein viertel von 1 meter 20
ist einfach durch 420 durch vier sind 30
genau es sind 30 zentimeter
kommen wir zur letzten matheaufgabe eine
wahl hat folgendes ergebnis kann die
data hat 32 prozent der stimmen kandidat
b hat 61 prozent und kandidat c hat
genau sieben prozent ok welches dieser
diagramme zeigt den wahlausgang richtig
bot jetzt nicht mehr als oder also dass
sie auf gar keinen fall da ist er bei 50
hier das hier könnte es sein allerdings
sind c&a da gleich groß dass das rechte
das rechte diagramm stellt den richtigen
ausgang da
wenn du jetzt einen vierten oder dritten
punkt gemacht hast hast du matte
bestanden ja und wir kommen zum letzten
fach gesellschaftskunde ich bin gespannt
die kombination aus geschichte erdkunde
und politik aufgabe 1 eine zwei
nachbarländer china ganz kurz mal
ich hab damals wirklich gehasst und ich
habe es nicht verstanden warum die
politik erdkunde und andere schon wieder
verstanden
allerdings können wir uns jetzt um zwei
nachbarländer von china auf jeden fall
oben russland das ist zu 100 prozent
klar und darunter indien was anderes
weiß ich jetzt nicht ich würde sagen
nordkorea oder syrien und deswegen muss
ich ein nachbar länder aufgelistet gucke
nach ob du richtig sagst und gibt
russland ist nia doch das und
nordkorea habe ich noch gesagt indien
tadschikistan da
die jemand der sich irgendwann mal
ausgedacht das gehalt das land gibt es
wollen weiter geht's mit politik was ist
eine koalition und was ist eine
opposition eine koalition ist das was
aktuell unsere regierung ist es ist ein
zusammenschluss von mehreren parteien
regieren und eine opposition ist eine
das weiß ich nicht die koalition ist ein
bündnis von parteien zur
regierungsbildung via mehr garten
ampelkoalition deutschland wird
beispielsweise zurzeit von einer
koalition regiert die opposition besteht
in einem parlament aus denjenigen
politischen parteien die nicht die
regierung bilden
also quasi alles andere
koalition spd grüne fdp und
oppositioneller quasi
cdu/csu/fdp der ganze baum star wenn du
das wusstest dann notiert ihr einen
punkt mehr weiter geht's wie heißt die
hauptstadt der usa ok go kart sagen wenn
ich das jetzt falsch mache dann bin ich
raus aber natürlich ganz klar
den freund das historische dc wofür
steht dies meine lieben freunde wissen
die kommentaren wir auch schon zur
letzten frage in welche besatzungszonen
wurde deutschland nach dem krieg
aufgeteilt scheiße ich dachte das vorhin
war schon die letzte frage in welche
besatzungszonen wurde deutschland ich
weiss es nicht ist es ist als mit brd
deutschland insgesamt vier
besatzungszonen auf
habe ich mich dann voll zum affen
gemacht ich irgendwas rausgehauen
bundesrepublik deutschland und die
deutsche demokratische republik dachte
ich jetzt gerade
ich bin durchgefallen
deutsche mutter hat sich alles richtig
aber das hier
scheiße also wenn du alle vier wusstest
dann notiere dir wieder einen punkt nun
musst du auch wieder gucken ob du
mindestens drei der vier fragen richtig
beantworten konnte mehr wenn ihr
insgesamt alle drei fächer also deutsch
mathe und gse mit jeweils drei oder vier
punkten geschafft habt dann habt ihr
unseren test bestanden
deutschland habe ich geschafft aber
gesellschaftskunde nicht dummer idiot
allerdings würde ich an der stelle das
heutige video beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch dieser hauptschule
test gefallen hat dann lassen kann einen
daumen hoch unter diesem video hier da
abonnieren ein kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr weitere videos nicht
verpassen wollen schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare auf welche videos sich
eventuell noch reagieren soll welche
tests mit hilfe soll ich noch machen
lässt
englisch war gar nicht dran dass man
englisch das macht egal